hi there steve kaufman here
uh i promised you shorter videos with uh
captions and translations
but today is not one of them today is uh
christmas day so i'm going to ramble a
bit and talk about christmas
and
try to somehow connect it to language
learning
christmas
um
you know many of the traditions that we
identify with christmas
of course historians will tell you that
it's sort of an amalgamation of
um aspects of ancient middle eastern
religions
uh for example uh a virgin giving birth
to a child is a tradition that existed
in other religions in the middle east
some of the traditions relate to roman
festivals saturnalia
obviously
in an attempt to appeal to the roman
population
christmas trees
christmas lights candles on christmas
trees apparently
come from the tradition in northern
europe of having great bonfires on the
darkest day of the year in order to
encourage the sun to come back and so
forth and so on
so i mean everything in in this
wonderful rich
uh human sort of
cultural tapestry that we live today is
the accumulation of
what people did before us
whether it be technology i mean modern
technology wouldn't be anywhere without
the contribution of chinese technology
and arab
technology and hindu mathematics
long ago
i mean the food that we eat today
so typically italian like tomatoes or
typically irish or german like potatoes
and and all these things came from the
new world uh peppers and so forth and so
on so everything that we enjoy today is
is a part of this
um
increasing globalization fusion mixture
of traditions and and foods and so forth
now within that
i feel that the phenomenon of
christianity is is quite spectacular
it started in the middle east
and initially most of the adepts lived
in the middle east north africa sort of
around the uh
around the mediterranean basin
today
uh the number of christians in that part
of the world is relatively small
although they do there are some
christianity today represents about one
third of the population of the world
speaking
a variety of languages obviously very
heavy in the americas therefore speaking
english french in
northern in north america uh spanish in
mexico with zija which is also part of
north america and then spanish and
portuguese through the rest of the
americas a little bit of french in haiti
and so forth
english course in guyana
and then of course this tremendous
growth of christianity in africa where
we have a wide variety of languages
all spoken by christians
and now in uh in asia and the pacific
islands uh
christianity has been growing
so that uh christianity which was
initially a religion of the middle east
became a religion of europe thanks to uh
rome imperial rome
uh but now the europe europe per se is a
relatively smaller party in fact if
anything christianity is in decline in
europe as people are becoming more
secular on the other hand is growing in
other parts of the world
uh so
in that sense christianity unites a lot
of people around a common
religion common granted there are
catholics and protestants and orthodox
and a great variety of christians
however
the the basic message of
christ i'm not a christian i'm not a
religious person but the basic message
of christ and the message of
christmas
is a very positive one it's about
peace
christ's message was one of helping the
weak the less fortunate
being tolerant being forgiving
uh and and obviously this was a very
powerful message because what started
out as
a few thousand people are very small
sort of
sect
uh in the middle east
uh
through a variety of circumstances the
their message or even the demographics
which is very powerful apparently the
christians had
better demographics because they help
each other better during times of plague
and disease and so forth and today of
course
as was pointed out by my son
who is a professor at the university of
london birkbeck college and he wrote a
book called the religious shall inherit
the earth
people who are religious have larger
families and so while there might be a
decline in religiosity in certain
countries of europe as people become
more secular this is more than
compensated for
by the high
fertility birth rate of the more
religious people whether they be
christians muslims
jews for that matter and but the message
of christmas really is a message that's
quite common to all religions after all
uh while
christians might account for somewhat
over 2 billion people in the world
muslims account for
not that much less
and of course we have hindus and we have
buddhists and in all of these religions
people are expressing largely
the same
need for human solidarity for peace
unfortunately
like everything human
it comes with the good and the bad
and so there have been
many examples of intolerance within
religion
fighting between sets between religions
and all the things that we really can't
just ascribe to religion per se but
rather ascribe to the difficult nature
of human beings
who find all kinds of reasons to fight
and squabble and be nasty to each other
now how does all of that relate back to
my favorite topic language learning
it's a stretch
however the fact that
christianity because we are talking not
about all religions we're talking about
the christian religion today
is a religion practiced by
i don't know apparently two-thirds of
the countries in the world and so
therefore the wide range of the range of
languages spoken by christians is
enormous
so there's a connection
uh
i think to learn about religions is to
learn about human beings just as to
learn about languages is to learn about
human beings
so you know what the attitude that i
have and i must say that my family
we're not religious but we also
celebrate christmas as many
non-christians do because we give
presents and we have
a dinner one evening at our place with
our uh son and his family and the
following day we're invited over to
their place with
with my son's mother-in-law and
brother-in-law
and so that it becomes an opportunity to
get together
uh which uh
you know is a wonderful thing for
christians to do
but it's also something that people of
all religions enjoy doing
so i guess
christmas the message is supposed to be
one of peace
uh
it's also
much commercialized but you can't blame
christianity for that that's also in our
nature we tend to be acquisitive
but uh but we like to give gifts and we
like to buy things for people we like to
think about what make what make them
what might make them happy and plus
we're happy when others think of us so
there you go it's a bit of a ramble
it's not
anything to do with language learning
those messages are coming in the new
year they'll be shorter
and they will have transcripts and
captions but this one doesn't so i wish
you all a merry christmas those of you
who are christians or who celebrate
christmas and i wish everyone a very
happy end of the year because there are
other holidays during this time of year
i wish everyone
a happy uh holiday period
and i hope that when you contemplate the
year that's gone by in the world we live
in that you do so with optimism and
generosity because i try to
i think we should all try to be upbeat
and on that note
i say goodbye and i look forward to
seeing you in the new year
bye for now